nathalie bondil est notre invité ce soir
directrice générale conservatrice en
chef du musée des beaux-arts de montréal
bonsoir dame de bondeville comment
accueillez-vous l'annoncent
d'aujourd'hui évidemment avec grand
plaisir est grand ou tonton puisque il
ya eu peu de noms sur ledit confinement
de la culture et que les bibliothèques
et les musées dont que soit parmi les
premiers c'est évidemment un signe
d'espoir pour le reste des acteurs de la
culture au québec
ouais et vous êtes prête vous au musée à
relancer les activités le 29 mai alors
en fait depuis le 17 avril avec les
trois musées nationaux et le musée des
beaux-arts de montréal nous avons
concocté des pistes de réflexion et de
solutions pour le déconfinement donc ça
fait déjà plus d'un mois avec le soutien
de la santé publique et nous avons eu
plusieurs tables rondes qui ont été
organisées avec mystère de la culture et
avec la société des musées du québec
avec donc là c est de s st et maintenant
nous voyons le résultat à partir du 29
mai les musées peuvent rouvrir peut-être
que certains musées en région pourront
ouvrir dès lors pour nous on me verra
doute bientôt mais un petit peu moins
car au cours du mois de juin donc vous
allez ouvrir cours mois de juin dans
votre cas c'est ça ben en fait oui c'est
ça ben assez bientôt mais le temps pour
pouvoir aménager les espaces
d'exposition suivant les règles
sanitaires
chico l'on doit suivre évidemment parce
qu'on veut s'assurer que le musée soit
vu comme un espace sécuritaire un espace
donc qu'ils soient réconfortant et
rassurant à la fois pour nos employés
mais aussi pour les publics
est-ce que ce qui fait passer depuis le
15 mars
maintenant vient changer le monde la
culture des musées le modèle d'affaires
de musées comme comme le vôtre
absolument c'est une très bonne question
évidemment il ya une grande variété dans
l'écosystème des musées vous avez des
institutions qui sont publiques et des
institutions qui sont privés
c'est sûr que les institutions publiques
donc voient leurs déficits
absorbée par l'état donc elle ne vise
pas du tout cette crise des revenus de
la même façon et les institutions
privées
dans le cas du musée des beaux-arts de
montréal donc comme nous devons
rechercher 60 % de nos revenus par un
autofinancement et notamment par la
billetterie
comme dans le cas d'autres musées privés
forcément ce qui n a pas été gagnées
pendant ces mois de fermeture est perdu
et bien entendu nous savons tous que
cette reprise va prendre du temps
c'est une crise qui met à mal notre
modèle d'affaires c'est-à-dire que les
outils aux nous utilisions auparavant ne
sont plus opérants de la même façon
qu'on pense au gala philanthropique qui
sont des rassemblements de centaines et
de centaines de personnes que ce soit
donc les chiffres liés aux
fréquentations des grandes expositions
maintenant nous sommes au défi de
réouvrir sans pour autant creuser le
déficit et surtout donc pour aller
chercher ces fameux revenus dont nous
avons besoin tout simplement pour payer
les salaires est ce que ça veut l'avenir
selon vous selon votre estimation que ça
prendra beaucoup plus d'argent public
pour remplacer l'argent privé perdu
alors je dois dire que pour le moment au
canada
effectivement nous avons le west 6/10
fonde qui est donnée par le fédéral se
penchera variable extrêmement la
subvention salariale merci et puis donc
il ya eu des des avances sur les
subventions qui ont été accordés
notamment par une serbe de la culture
pour les coûts de fonctionnement
donc ça a permis donc à la trésorerie de
pouvoir être allégé après je vous dirais
que on a fait toutes sortes de
réinvention des budgets on a évidemment
drastiquement réduit tous nos coûts qui
sont liées donc aux opérations ou aux
expositions afin de pouvoir être
moins coûteux mais on a quand même
réussi donc à inventer et un scénario
solidaire qui nous permet de passer au
travers de cette tempête et qui je crois
donc que nous amènera à la fin de
l'exercice financier dans l équilibre
comme nous souhaitons mais c'est pas
gagné
il ya beaucoup d'efforts à faire il ya
beaucoup de créativité et de réinvention
pour vivre comme pour le partenaire
d'ailleurs il phare est un modèle
temporaire je présente dans votre esprit
en tout cas c'est un modèle avec lequel
nous allons vivre pendant l'exercice
financier actuel probablement pendant
l'exercice financier futur de toute
façon tant qu'il n'y aura pas de
traitement ou de vaccins on ne s'attend
pas à pouvoir revivre le musée de la
même façon c'est pour ça que cette crise
est très différente de celle de 2008 que
j'avais pu vivre vous souvenez
évidemment de la crise des subprimes ce
parce que vous pouvez utiliser les mêmes
outils
quelque part pour pouvoir opérer le
musée à l'heure actuelle nous que la
nôtre station de fonctionner et
profondément altérée si je puis dire
il ya des bons côtés c'est à dire que
l'on va pouvoir offrir une expérience
très exclusive très intime des visiteurs
qui seront moins nombreux à pouvoir
rencontrer les oeuvres d'art à howard y
ait cette immersion dans le musée donc
l'expérience va être certainement plus
qualitative on l'est évidemment les
normes que nous avions en termes
quantitatifs sont très différents un mot
en terminant les musées c'est une bonne
nouvelle mais le reste du secteur de la
culture il ya eu beaucoup de déception
notamment pour les arts de la scène qui
sont toujours à l'arrêt est-ce qu'on
aurait voulu est ce que vous auriez
voulu en savoir davantage aujourd'hui
alors c'est sûr pour les musiques une
sommes heureux de pouvoir être là
notamment pour montréal métropole
culturelle cet été donc avec des
expositions comme au mieux comme paris
autant d'impressionnisme que nous allons
ouvrir mais il est vrai que montréal a
cette réputation par ces festivals qui
ne sont pas là et par toutes les scènes
cal théâtrale et de danse d'opéra qui
font vibrer la ville et en cela donc
c'est très important que montréal puisse
continuer à faire résonner dans toutes
ces scènes parce que ce sont beaucoup
d'artistes donc ce sont les arts vivants
et montréal doit garder ce niveau de
référence de rayonnement pas simplement
pour les publics montréal et mais aussi
parce que nous sommes une grande
métropole culturelle ça serait très
dommage que à l'international on voit
des villes qui réouvre donc leurs scènes
de concert d'opéra de théâtre et que
nous restions silencieux moria ne peut
pas un stimulant sur c'est celle là
merci beaucoup
nathalie bon dieu merci à vous